بلغ منصه الكترونيه تطلقها وزاره الداخليه
العراقيه للابلاغ عن المحتوى الهابطي
والموسيقى او ما يبث رسائل مجتمعيه سلبيات
او تلك الخارجيه للحياه جعله منصات
التواصل والمواقع الاعلاميه وصناعها تحت
مجهر الرقابه بهدف الحفاظ على الزائقه
العامه للمجتمع العراقي
[موسيقى]
المبادره تعد ايجابيه بالنسبه للكثيرين
بالتزامن معا انتشار من يطلق عليهم بصناع
المحتوى الفارغ وترويج مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لمواد توصف بالاسفافي والابتذال
حتى ان المعارضين لهذا النوع من المحتويات
صاروا يقعونا بفخ التسويق لها من خلال
انتقالها
اخرى تعبر عن قلقها من تلك من الصالحين
البعض انها لم تضع معايير واضحه في وصف
المحتوى الخادش والموسيقى تستخدم من قبل
البعض لتصفيه حسابات شخصيه من خلال
البلاغات الكيديه او قد تتخذها الجهات
المعنيه وسيله للطريق على الحريات بدريعه
بس ما لا يلائم المجتمع زينب صباح العربيه
بغداد